i was thinking about the queen right i'm
like when i think of a raw family i
think of the queen
and look it might be treasonous but she
ain't no fitty
here ye hear ye hear ye gather round
for this week's episode off she doesn't
read the news with me
town crier chris turner oh you're trying
so very hard i'm alice wynn your wife
it's my wife of course i try hard as an
entertainer i give my heart and soul i
leave it all
on stage he has no splatter here oh
hello miss italian what sprezzatura
if i'm not mistaken is something that
was very big in the renaissance
it was um sort of studied carelessness
it was like oh i'm actually just very
good at sculpting i don't work at it
it's just that i'm very good at it
naturally
here's the david that's very cool that's
very cool i'm trying to think if i've
ever used any sprezzatura in my life
maybe i would say studied carelessness
isn't the right word but
the whole concept of walking on stage in
a
you know a woolly jumper and being like
hello i'd like to do a wrap for you all
is you know misleading in a way are your
glasses dirty would you clean them
yes of course so i don't know if people
know this but um women's clothes are
often made of fabric that will
not clean glasses and my favorite thing
when else gives me her glasses to clean
is i do this joke please don't leak
and she hates it it's even worse when
she gives me her contact lenses
um one of the most sensual moments in
the book lolita which obviously is a
dangerous thing to say is when he
licks something out of her eye he has
she has something caught in her eye and
he
gently licks it out of her eye like a
[ __ ] creep
yeah well he is a creep but also there
was a chris you're not one of those
people who reads lolita and it's like
it's actually a really sympathetic
portrayal of
pedophilia no what i'm saying is
in japan there was a craze of ocular
linctus which is when teenagers were
licking each other's eyes
um and then they realized it was
spreading diseases like blepharitis and
conjunctivitis yeah i can imagine so
so there we go i've never been to japan
but uh it made me want to go
there you go nice and clean nice clean
glasses well
alice let's have some italian stories
because i'm
i don't really have anything to share
this week are you really putting me on
the spot here what do you mean italian
well you
used an italian word of italy
well i don't know like but you know a
lot about italy you've been there you've
studied italian in italy
i have forgotten all the italian i
studied but it's true i do find the
whole concept of studying italian in
italy
interesting because you went to school
where they only spoke in italian correct
yes how do you even cope about how do
you cope with that no i think that's the
best way to learn
so i have a theory about this i don't
think it's easy to learn a language
unless you can flirt
with someone in that language which is
why latin is so difficult
um and it's also the excuse that you
have for why you flirted with all those
italian men
ocho darling i had no choice it was the
linguistic imperative
how do you reply to ciao bella what's
the standard reply i've forgotten all my
italian i think the only thing i can say
in italian now is i don't remember how
to speak italian
i i love italy when i've been and
the place i've been to has not been
naples which is a [ __ ]
um any neapolitans listening i do
apologize that you live in a [ __ ] city
chris
look it's just it's run by the mafia
it's riddled with crime
chris has a habit of sort of just idly
crossing off whole countries on the map
and just like not there cities
i like italy and people on my gig
mailing list if you sign up to it which
uh
you should to get alerts well chris
where can they sign up for it
um bit dot lee
slash chris giggs
i don't even know you have such a [ __ ]
i'll link it in the youtube description
or in the podcast description
but when um when you sign up for it it
says at the bottom of the email
um if i'm not forming in your city i do
apologize
it's probably just because i can't fit
on the tour or it's one of the two
cities i hate
several people have asked and i wrote
that as a joke but
since then i'm like oh no naples is one
of them i have no stories this week
nothing happened to me
i i did a show for some lovely people
did a zoom gig and that was really nice
um anyone listening who was there thank
you so much for coming it was available
to all
all who cared to come uh you can
actually find out about the new ones
that are happening
the link will be in the description of
the podcast or the youtube video
uh it's dot lee slash zoom gigs with a
capital z and a capital g
at the start of gigs don't capitalize on
the end of it um
and that was really nice my parents were
there my sister was there
and they provided insight for a wrap so
if you haven't
watched that i mean it's not out yet but
it will be out in the next couple of
weeks
keep an eye out for that and sign up to
come to a future one that was really fun
i enjoyed
doing that it was nice to get back to
doing shows for
like an audience who were there to see
me essentially
um it felt very very special we had
lovely ivan decker as a guest he's
lovely
he's very nice um yeah have you done
anything this week
i mean yes what have you done we just
sound very um
accusatory no no no no one thing i like
being in america is i always kind of
question myself with words like
accusatory i'm like do they say
accusatory because
you know in america they're like
advertisement
and in britain we say advertising so
they think we say
advertisement which we don't
advertisement i think some people say i
think we say advertisement but they
think we say things differently and so i
always catch myself going
like oh i'm i'm recommending wait in
america they say recommending
i don't know it's very difficult it's
challenging yeah no so it was just
have you have you got up to anything
this week i um
tweeted some students that was always
good good good fun
one of my students after i played her a
piece by mozart
said that he was lit as hell
and by the way there's no way that she
wasn't doing that to make me
to make me feel sort of vague outrage
and delight um
she was definitely acting up i think she
was describing mozart as lit as hell or
describing herself as little no no no i
think she was describing
mozart's marriage of figaro overture as
lit as hell but that's how those would
have been described back in the day
right
like he would have played it and people
would have gone this is our banger
on that subject yes tell us about the
time you played that
silent disco with your classical bangers
playlist uh
chris and i have played a variety of
silent discos
and and it does not usually go that well
for me
chris is fine chris you know i panda i
i'm the one who's like you want some
flume i'll play you some flow
so we were doing we did like these three
nights of um
of silent djing and so i would have like
my own channel let's clarify silent
discus for people who've never been to
one
imagine a normal disco club night you
can hear the sound of the speakers
silent disco you get a little headset
and you can switch between
maybe one of three channels on which a
different dj is playing on each channel
and the colors on the outside of your
headphones change so the djs can see
what you're listening to and one of the
fun things when you're at one
is you'll be dancing and then you
suddenly see everyone else's earphones
are blue and you're like i'm pretty sure
i'm on green
and then you switch over and you're like
journey don't stop
believing and there's nothing worse than
um leaving a side of disco
and then suddenly realizing as you leave
now that your headphones are off
that everyone in the silent disco is a
[ __ ]
how can you tell because they're wearing
headphones there's no sound all there is
is just this sort of like grunting
sweaty movement sound and then people
going
don't stop believe me it is
very fun for anyone who's so like these
silent discos we played were in perth at
the fringe world festival
and there would always be a huge line of
people trying to get in because these
were on friday and saturday nights
and i mean it was always a problem when
we played those saturday night spots
okay so i took my mine as an opportunity
to do various social experiments
so the first one i did was um you gave
someone a switch and said press this it
will electrocute everyone else's
headphones now
really you were like yes i was wearing a
laptop and i couldn't say no
no um so i okay so the first night i
played
just a playlist of um i think
it was just bangers by women so it was
mostly pop
and it was like it only had female
singers yeah it was it was robin and
lady gaga it's a good playlist
it was fun yeah uh people liked it very
popular um
but a lot of guys gave me nasty looks or
would like come up to me and be like can
you play something good
and i'd be like i mean i am playing
something like good as a subjective term
can you play something i like
so that was that was the first night
then i contrasted it in the second night
by playing
nothing but classic rock to which uh
sort of
demographically the same men would come
up to me and just be like it's really
great to see a woman who actually has
good taste in music for once
uh sorry they didn't call me a woman
they call me a girl obviously um
anyway so that was fun and then
the last night i um made up a list of
classical music bangers and it was just
like um you know the blue danube
uh etc just absolute smashing
smashing hits of the 18th 19th and 20th
centuries and
am i correct in thinking that there was
one time so it was me playing on one
channel
my my boys playing on the other channel
you playing on one channel
and some of us are playing like some
absolute like
smash hit and then in the floor there's
just two people waltzing to something
from your playlist
cutting through all the sweaty people
the the real it showed
the um it showed the true genius of
strauss ii the blue danube because when
i put on strauss the second the blue
danube
everyone [ __ ] turned over to that and
they were everyone paired up
and waltzed around and it's an absolute
banger what a great piece of music
yeah i i love doing those things so i
used to do them with my sketch my
improv group and we would have two
channels one me
pandering to tastes the other one would
be daniel's norwegian disco which no one
listened to
and then the channel in between was just
our podcast
not this one but the podcast i have with
them and we just put episodes of it so
you see people switch on and go wait
what's that let's sit down be confused
maybe have a chuckle
and then go back to dancing that was
always that was always fun
yeah oh yeah i missed those mr silent
disc goes
oh good they were good they were good
reminiscing
so one thing i did is i tried to give
tick tock more of a chance
um i have this bad habit of only coming
to social media platforms four years
after they're
cool or like after they've really
stopped being cool so for instance
i was i was like on myspace so long
after everyone else had left my spa it
was just me my friend caroline sim
and tom and tom and caroline sim and i
were just shouting to the void at each
other and it was actually great i mean
it was
it was like a wilderness there was no
one there it was like the wild west
like gone backwards it was so cool but
um finally we
packed it in and went on facebook um at
which point it was pretty much just mums
so you know i i have this history of
being too late to the game
so i thought you know what i've just got
to give this tick tock thing a try right
i mean it looks
really stupid but maybe i'm wrong and i
tried it for an hour and it was really
stupid
and then i talked to a friend of mine
who does like tech stuff and i was like
uh a
tock stupid and he's like that's like
saying books are stupid you just haven't
found the right book
and i was like fair point fair point and
then he reminded me that the
um the algorithm kind of operates like
the sorting hat
it like it knows you really like it just
it finds out your secret proclivities
and it
like finds out who you are and it's
almost when i went on tick tock it just
gave me
15 second videos of humber humber
licking a young girl's eye and it was
like
no i'm not the type of person who sides
with him in the novel
it's a joke about lolita he's called
humber humber that's his name and no one
knew who was a pedophile
what um so i think that's a pseudonym i
don't think it's real it's his real name
within the book anyway
uh so the first hour i went as i said
nothing good second hour
it started to figure out what i liked
and i didn't know this was going to be
what i liked but here is what i like
apparently
i like videos about very beautiful trans
women
telling me like commonly asked questions
they get
that's like all i get on tiktok now and
i have to say there's a reason i keep
getting it because i'm just i'm like i
just watch
all of the videos um and then
occasionally
no that's really it i guess it turns out
that um i
only want to use tick-tock uh from an
authorial perspective and
through which i can investigate
identities different to my own
because you need to that was a news
story this week was amanda gorman
the the poet from bayern's inauguration
yes
there were translators that had been
told they weren't allowed to translate
her poem because they
were not black women um and your mother
as a translator i think was like oh yeah
this is this is you know interesting but
also let's not make it so that
you have to be because one of the
arguments was i translate herodotus
i'm not a greek man from the past i
think that that's uh
not a something the argument would be
that well yeah because there's not a
greek man from the past available yes
but it's not even that it's also just
like think about
it's about power structures right and i
don't i don't have a settled opinion on
this subject
but i think that comparison is is
uh a bit useless because um ancient
greek men are not being oppressed
correct ancient greek men are not being
oppressed no one is saying hey
stop having sex with people through
their legs those who
don't know intra-cruel sex inter-cruel
sex
is where you do not have sex up
someone's bum
you have sex between their thighs and so
a lot of the
the old greeks were doing that with
little boys weren't they the only way
oscar will just like to have sex with
men
i don't know only but you know
predominantly yeah maybe you did a bit
of you know neck
like neck neck to shoulder can you stop
trying to think of all the different
ways
under the arm to the side the neck um
the knee to the chest oh there we called
i don't go
that's like used to tight grip i don't
know enough loud nor greek to be able to
coin this new word
yeah how does even inter-cruel work what
is this like the crores
between your legs the cross crosses i
don't know and i don't care to know
oh well wonderful well that's um let's
tell the news we've we've
expanded and elucidated on our rather
empty week but the week's not been empty
of news now this we recorded this
podcast last week
right before the oprah interview was
broadcast in america i thought it was
weird it was broadcast on two different
days it was there was over here and then
they did it the next day in the uk
like just team up and broadcast it at
you know lunchtime over here and then
evening over there
the new story is the the most privileged
um an ancient institution at the heart
of britain is racist
that's the news story shock yes right
that's the thing that's
not a surprise the queen the queen
and prince philip who has said so many
ridiculously offensively racist things
to people all over history
um yeah i mean that was the big story to
state my opinion
i bloody love the royal family all of
them just want them to get on be nice
and watching the interview you made you
love them even more you were like
yes take her down a peg i have not
watched the interview
all i want is for them to all be nice to
each other that's all i want
yeah i mean it to me
it wasn't that surprising what was
surprising was the the kind of actual
fact of it like a member of the royal
family asking
how dark their child that didn't
surprise me in the least
i just i was just like how are you that
open about it
like that that is i don't think that's
someone trying to be i think that's
someone going
oh this is a fair question to ask megan
well it's also a stupid question because
megan doesn't know
the answer to that question no she has
ultrasound scans
i felt really sad for megan i think of
course what [ __ ]
uh terrible time i liked that article
that you sent me in the irish times
about um i mean it was a very funnily
written article
but the main premise was you know megan
is not
an underdog commoner who's married into
this magical family
megan is from the ascendant power aka
american celebrity culture yeah harry
has married into
american celebrity culture yeah no no
one's thinking the royal family is
getting stronger the royal family is not
on the uh no you know and something i
think about is i follow on instagram a
lot of um
a lot of instagram accounts that just
put up pictures of various royal
family members from all around europe
and like there are some adorable swedish
princesses and no one gives a [ __ ]
about them like why are we all so
interested in the british royal family
that's it they're not hot uh disagree
who's hot okay so 18 year old prince
william was [ __ ] gorgeous oh yeah but
he's not 18 years old
it doesn't matter there's a hot man
inside him and sort of
sort of temporarily um and then i think
kate
middleton's gorgeous and she has such
good hats and then uh megan is gorgeous
and then harry i guess i was thinking
about it i was thinking about the
queen right i'm like when i think of a
raw family i think of the queen
and look it might be treasonous but she
ain't no fitty
to use a double negative which would
upset her i think the saddest thing to
come from the megan and harry interview
was that she
said well you know there were points
where i was considering suicide which
obviously is
horrendous and that
that leads on to a kind of interrelated
story
if if we're done kind of amusing about
them with piers morgan
um so for those that don't know piers
morgan right wing [ __ ]
who has just a career in the uk
that stretched so long tried to do a
talk show in america
oh here's a question is he are he and
katie hopkins like
two sides of the same coin um i think
she is more overtly racist than him
they should like hang out they should
hang out
oh god that'd be terrible um yeah them
and nigel ferrara should hang out and we
should always know where they are so we
don't need to go near there
um so piers morgan he
yeah he just he had a very firmly held
opinion
that he has yet to even address which
was now she's making it up
she just wants attention i don't think
she ever felt depressed or to kill
herself
people are very quick to decide someone
wants attention and i remember
thinking about this as a teenager when
like you know it was very
in uh to whenever someone you know had
some kind of disaster
with their mental health everyone else
just be like so attention-seeking and i
was like
listen if you need attention so much
that you've got to cut yourself
then you need a tent someone needs to
give you the attention
like what's good you sort it the phrase
it's a cry for help and it's you know
are you walking past a public pond and
you see a child
you little attention seeker oh yeah
yeah if you know what if i was in your
position i'd be quiet about it like
really
it's interesting there's a sort of
conflict i think between um
you know more victorian
uh and maybe even like greek ancient
greek kind of like classical hellenistic
social norms about um stoicism
that are at odds with the more modern
like self-care
culture of you know ask for help when
you need it
and the the criticism of someone asking
for help when they need it is oh they
are attention seeking which is like yeah
correct they would like to get attention
for the help
for like the the thing they are having a
problem with yeah
where so what what would the victorian
slash greek approach be
well i think much more don't don't
[ __ ] complain man up
okay that's the let that man [ __ ] you
between your legs
i um that's a whole separate thing but
anyway no i i think that there was
uh you know a lot of focus on on stiff
upper lip don't
don't show oh this is a stiff upper lip
between the lip and the other bit of the
lip is where you could
have sex with someone yeah how small
is your penis chris look i don't i don't
wanna
i mean you'd think i'd know by now but
in fact
i'm gonna leave that in even though it's
my wife mocking my genitals um
let me tell you an anecdote that i don't
think i've
spoken about here before about the um
the french carriage
over the alps no i've never heard of
this this is a secondhand uh
anecdote um but uh yeah so it's like
it's
sorry as in you were not in this
carriage
i was not in this carriage what i mean
is i think my mother read it somewhere
uh so it's like the eighteen let's just
say this could be absolute [ __ ]
we've been told things by your like
diane sawyer's terrible death which is
this cat
this could have been in azerbaijan and
it was a donkey train
but i think whether or not the story is
true sort of as irrelevant i think it
demonstrates a truth
so um the story was uh it was the 18th
century roughly
uh and it was a coach like a carriage um
with some englishmen and some frenchmen
going through the alps
and the roads were very windy and narrow
how do you know they were windy and not
windy
it's a real flaw of the english language
that how do you know were there gusts of
wind or was it snaking along the roads
were windy were they windy
are we rowing are we rowing who knows
continue after that excellent diversion
you're welcome
english language makes allowances for
context chris
yeah but it's a windy road or a windy
road where's the contents beyond that
you make you you figure it out chris
the english language doesn't pander to
your your
child why would it a large black and
white bear to my needs
um so windy snakey
road and um they lost control of the
horses and the horses started
running like galloping down these roads
really really dangerously
and um it looked like they were going to
go over the edge and we have we have
this story like mainly from their
diaries i think anyway or letters they
wrote
so the frenchmen uh just
lose it they like scream they cry
they're like
you know they just lose it the
englishman meanwhile
hold their heads up like gentlemen and
don't make a sound that
you know white knuckled hands on their
knees as they accept
with resignation uh that they may have
to die right
by the next day the frenchmen are
fine they're over it they're like wasn't
that lulls the other day when we almost
died in the carriage
and the englishmen have like ptsd about
it like they are not over it and like
weeks later they are still freaking out
about it right and
i don't know if this holds up
scientifically
uh but i i think that um that kind of
shows a contrast between
uh what i described right like this more
old-fashioned stoical culture
versus more modern self-care
attention-seeking culture and i say
attention seeking without meaning it in
a negative
context um yeah i think there's a
contrast between those two and i think
um they're they're very opposed to each
other it makes total sense to me
that someone who values really highly
qualities like um suffering without
complaint
is going to look at megan and be like
that's [ __ ]
but someone who values seeking help when
they need it
is going to look at those complaints and
be like that's
evil yeah so i think with piers morgan
it wasn't him saying
oh if you feel like this just deal with
it it was him going you're lying you're
making this up to make the royal family
look bad for attention piers morgan is
oh other countries so what happened he
had to leave
the show that he was part of good
morning britain after an argument on air
with his co-host
um who said what are you saying why do
you think this and
he just said i'm not having this and he
walked off and then i think i assume
what happened was the show asked him to
apologize and he refused to
because he still hasn't and so he was
asked to leave the show and so he did
and he's just been on twitter going i
have a right to my opinion you're like
yeah but you're also a dick i guess
there's the whole thing of like you have
a right to an opinion but do you have do
you have a right to a platform
i don't think piers morgan's gonna
struggle to find ways to get people to
listen to him no
but i do think there is a wider question
there of
um you know censorship generally yeah i
mean they gave him an opportunity to
apologize he could have
continued holding that he could have
been like i feel this but i understand
this
it had the most complaints of anything
that's been on british tv
ever wow it broke the record of because
in britain you can complain to ofcom
um who then investigate it he could have
said
look i feel this way and i express
myself i apologize
to people i've upset megan herself
complained
not about her but about i think it was
about
him essentially denying anyone who you
know
saying this is going to have an impact
on people saying oh if i tell someone
are they going to react like him
you know if at least people killing
themselves i mean that is yeah and
that's a very fair criticism of the
people who are
who are saying that megan's making it up
which i don't really
i always find that so strange like what
makes you think you know
what's going on inside another person's
head it just seems so presumptuous
yeah the most you know it's like i i
guess i always feel like
um you know there's two risks there's
the risk of
believing someone who's making it up for
attention and then
later feeling like a fool right not that
bad a risk
or there's the risk of not believing
someone who
should have been believed and then that
person later killing themselves
quite a big risk you have to map that up
i just don't think that
you have to like yeah there was a really
good tweet which was
um about you know when robin williams
killed himself people said oh why didn't
he ask for help
right when meghan markle says oh i was
feeling really depressed
ugh stop attention seeking
you know it's uh it's a big old sticky
web
oh i hear a cat we just took a break to
deal with uh the weekly
with corruption there catrion cattrian
very good um colonel woods is here
looking very elegant and floof another
news story
this this happened i think i showed you
this already on the monday after we
recorded
but um mackenzie scott jeff bezos's
ex-wife
the 22nd richest person in the world has
married a high school
science teacher and he's you know he's a
normal looking guy
congratulations good on him he's made a
bunch of money a bunch of money
i bet she has a pretty good prenup
though in fact oh yeah that's very true
that's very true i mean she's been good
she's um
she's on a sign up for a thing called
the giving pledge which billionaires
joined saying that they will give away
the majority
or most of their fortunes to
philanthropic causes is it true
that jeff bezos could just end world
hunger yes there is a twitter account
called how's jeff bezos ended world
hunger and it's
every day no and that person who runs
that account is always dealing with
people messaging going
it's not liquid it's in shares the value
of thing and then the guy just breaks
down like no it wouldn't actually even
cost that much money he has
he has that um you know or he could say
he owns 22
of amazon he's so it's just so funny
that oh gosh
calm down cat are you oh okay you're
de-matting him as we talk
um so yeah he's upset because he wanted
to marry mackenzie scott he wanted to be
the richest cat in the world
yeah what really freaks me out about our
cat is that the cat
doesn't know that there's been a
pandemic like we've tried
it's been a year and he just doesn't
know he's like why can't i go outside
[ __ ] this mask he has some pretty strong
views about the vaccine he's like
i'm okay with the the astrazeneca but
not with the
pfizer yeah yeah a lot of people aren't
okay with the astrazeneca there's been a
there was a study which was just
preposterous and this just shows how
crazy and how people don't understand
science countries are stopping giving it
because
there was a report from a country that
six people had got blood clots after
having it
and if you look at the the occurrence of
blood clots in a population
that is perfectly normal and i think
some scientists even said
oh no the number of blood clotted people
who've had it is actually much lower
than the national average
but now there are countries who are
saying well we're not going to give it
i was on a pill briefly that um made my
skin
just look like the fountain of youth i
was so gorgeous when i was using this
pill
and then i was just giggling around once
just to see i don't know i just wanted
to see like what the side effects of the
pill were and i discovered that it was
illegal
in both france and america because it
just had
so many blood clot problems
and i went back to my nhs doctor and i
was like hey
so i think this pill is like deadly and
he said you didn't fly here to visit me
did you
because that's a problem and he was like
uh is it and i was like yeah i think so
and he like googled it and he was like
oh yeah
yeah you're not supposed to be on this
one for longer than six months and i was
like i've been on it for two years and
he was like um
not great by the way i've mentioned your
skin looks lovely how are you doing that
i also had a hard time getting on that
pill and i had because
um the nhs will always try and get you
on to the cheapest pill first
right and the problem is that the cheap
i mean the problems with the
contraceptive pill are numerous but the
cheapest pill
um was known to cause problems with your
skin
and i wanted to go on the pill because i
was having problems with my skin
so my um nhs doctor i was 19 was like
okay well we have a policy we start you
off on this pill and i
just went off on this like oscar-worthy
speech and i was like
looking back actually i think it
revealed quite a lot of um aging
troubles i was having at the time but i
was like i have
three hot years left okay and if you
and you put on that voice as well really
to try and
i was like if you blight the rose of my
youth
and he was like all right look fine he
was he was like a starter doctor he was
like 25 or something and there's just
this
freaking out teenage girl just being
like i'm not gonna be hot
for much longer you know when you call
up like customer service they say this
call will be used for training purposes
i reckon that scenario is now used for
training purposes for junior doctor
and what will you do if a very pretty
very angry teenage girl demands you give
her the pill she wants
well i got it even though it was
apparently perilous
well maybe he just was like right fine
i'll give you the one that gives you
blood clots then
you have that i've heard this rumor a
lot and i don't know if it's true i've i
i have a bad habit of only reading the
headlines of articles
so i have heard that there has been a
fair amount of study
into a um male contraceptive like the
pill for men
but that the one whenever they've come
up with one
they do trials on men and the men are
always like well this gives me mood
swings
and like headaches and headaches and
depression and fatigue so i don't want
to take it
and the scientists are like oh yeah well
we can't have that
which is outrageous because obviously
like that that's the case with the
female contraceptive and we just kind of
[ __ ]
suck it up and do it you know yeah but
yours gone about how women have a higher
pain threshold
do i no not you you as in a monolithic
gender
hi we are monolithic gender all we're
gonna need to get started is one
suggestion
it's our favorite game whenever you hear
a phrase you like you
say it as if you're to you're like a
horribly embarrassing impression and
then take a suggestion
of it i was part of a clinical trial
when i was at university because i
wanted
money and it's so weird that that's a
thing we do
like we'll pay you money for taking this
experimental medicine and again as a
teenager
well yeah i don't know what the other
option is but it's just i think the fact
is a lot of students sign up for them
just going well is good about my health
but i need that money right
and they were testing the
whether it was a drug that had already
been approved it was an antiemetic so an
anti-vomiting drug that was given to
people undergoing chemotherapy
because chemotherapy induces nausea
right
and this drug they were like this is
safe however we're not really sure if
it's good for your brain
we think it might make you really angry
so
they gave me this pill and for the first
week i was
very sure i had a placebo because i felt
nothing and then i did a sketch comedy
show
where the whole way through i just was
out of it lost it i have a recording of
that show it's mad to listen back to it
i'm not being funny i'm not being not
funny i'm just being like
what's wrong with chris why is he doing
that and afterwards they they were like
are you all right
like people thought i was drunk but like
but that's not how a drunk person
behaves
and then so i went back for the final
checkup
and they did like a full clockwork
orange thing on me
they put me in a chair and they said
we're going to show you some photos
some images some videos and we want
to monitor arousal
whether that's sexual or anger
and so i had to be shown these images
and the woman showing the girls
some of these images will be um
titillating
and they were pictures of like a woman
in a negligee
from a catalogue a
dog a car crash they were so mild
compared to
like full-on clockwork orange right like
horrendous atrocities
and i i said to them i said will you
give me the results to study when
they're they never did
so i never found out whether this drug
is making people
super mad i didn't feel any different
maybe that's why you're so angry at me
all the time
yes because of this the long-lasting
effects of that thing yeah
the only person i'm angry was that
doctor who was trying to fob you off
with the not pretty skin pill
well done chris for that mediocre call
back
um i mentioned dogs there's a dog story
do you wanna hear the dog story
go on you know joe biden got his dogs
okay yeah so it was a big deal that
trump never had a dog and biden's got
dogs and he got a rescue dog called
i think major well right because he's a
real american yeah yeah real americans
have dogs and he has in the white house
and
they've now had to go back home to his
family home in delaware because one of
them bit a secret service agent oh no
he's just so sad um and one of the best
things come out of it was
the fox the fox like press corps guy
just kept asking questions about it so
jen saki
paske the press secretary i saw a clip
of her just going
yes and he goes so with the dot and she
went oh
another dog question
and he's like so can you assure the
public that um the dog won't be put down
and she just goes you see her just go
what and she's like well he's a family
member so no we won't
put the dog down i don't know don't they
usually put down dogs when they bite
somebody i think the dog possibly
then came out the dog probably didn't
bite the secret service agent they
probably just scratched him
you know um and you know trump rode
around
sick with covered in a car with secret
service agents and we didn't put him
down
so they um weren't dogs and people love
dogs
yeah yeah i mean it's you know people
love
people love well-behaved animals which
is why colonel willis is so good he's a
good
he's just you can't see he's just
sleeping over there and i know some of
you'll be like oh this is all like the
elk all over again show us the cute
sleeping cat you saw
him when he was here if you're listening
i'm sorry you didn't see him you just
heard him but he's got an instagram
colonel within so you can go search that
and you can see his pretty fluffy face
um so yeah biden hasn't got any dogs in
the white house anymore
which is that's sad right if that's
where you are most the time you want
your dog there with you especially if
you've only got two years left to live
what sorry alice win is that
are you are you threatening something
that's not
he's just i've got a plan actually to
assemble the correct fireplace that's
very old
he's very old that was that was um a a
glib
and tasteless joke are you excited for
the olympics
for the listener alice just looked at me
very confused if she does not know what
that word means no i know what the
olympics are
i didn't know that there were any
olympics do well they were due to be
olympics in 2020 and obviously they
didn't happen all right
they got pushed back to 2021 do you know
where they're happening to tokyo yeah
tokyo well done hey look at me
yeah um so are you excited um
no i'm much more of a figure skater girl
uh the winter olympics thank you yeah so
that was just meant to be a simple segue
where you were gonna go yeah i am
excited i go well the people
of japan aren't because 91 of people
have said that the olympics if they go
ahead should not have any
uh visitors from abroad um japan's been
really slow with the vaccine roll up i
believe because they have a system
whereby
they have to do their own tests amongst
their own population
which i wonder if it comes from japan
and i studied them in my anthropology
degree are really quite
weird about their like
japan seems very racist essentially when
you break it down you're like oh
japan's like no we are a superior race
to every other race right if you
are not fully japanese like many people
there just go
oh well you're not japanese like there
are japanese people who've moved out of
japan move back and get told
well you're not japanese yeah i i had a
friend who was living in kyoto and she
said that she knew a girl who
like only spoke japanese had been born
in japan raised in japan had never lived
anywhere outside of japan
but when she asked her where she was
from she was like i'm korean
because her parents are korean but she'd
never been to korea she couldn't speak
like but you still
she still couldn't like identify as
japanese
uh but they also have tons and tons of
old people don't they they're japanese
so so maybe that's yeah yeah
that may be true they do and they have a
declining birth rate as well
um um so i can see why you know if you
have a country filled with
old people you don't really necessarily
want the you know old people killing
virus to spread
yeah or maybe you do i don't think japan
want that you try to make up their evil
as well as racism no i'm not trying to i
don't know i just mean you know
some people think that it's a convenient
virus that kills off just the old people
yeah
i remember in my my japanese
anthropology class i was one of the few
non-japanese people
and our teacher was not japanese but you
know who lived in japan his family was
japanese
and he he would ask questions you know
we'd have to give presentations
so one of the questions was is japan a
homophobic society and they argued no we
have
the most uh gay clubs in the world like
a concentration of it in one of the
districts in tokyo and we had these gay
pride parades but i
gave this presentation saying well the
gay pride parades have no photography
rules
and in japan um you're being gay is
considered a fetish in the same way
though you can like be married to your
wife and then you go
and like do a bit of gay stuff yeah you
can be gay if you are married and have
children that's just accepted
and so i argued that it was it was a
homophobic society
uh and that's not to say that other
societies aren't no pretty much every
society is a homophobic society like
it's not like they're they're like oh no
this isn't fair
um and after i gave my presentation
uh several of them were like chris we
didn't realize you were gay
and i had to explain no you can you can
say that something's homophobic while
being straight if you support the rights
of an oppressed group of people that
means you are now
part of the oppressed group of people i
mean a lot of them don't want to visit
the
you know the poll they don't want the
olympics to happen i like the olympics
it's nice
i mean admittedly it's not my country
that's going to be invaded by loads of
people and giving viruses to but
i like the olympics it's it's fun to
have something on
and see yes i like the olympics i think
they represent something sort of noble
and and um you know good like
civilized right it makes me happy every
time i see
say like the shot put and it's always
won by someone from estonia
and they're like yes we ought to come
through to make shots put those and like
you just see them just like yeah mate
you
are wow you've really gone all in on
this kind of shot-putter program
those though the shot put is really
just a very silly event you are the best
person in the world at throwing a heavy
ball with one hand from your neck
those people would have done so well in
like
caveman times i thought you're gonna say
zombie apocalypse i thought no
i think that's a flawed thing like hit
that zombie okay one second
but do you know what it should be what
should be a an olympic sport is
cheerleading
and the i think i mean okay there's a
couple of reasons you're biased i am
biased because i'm a trivia but i was
not a good cheerleader like
have you seen i mean i've shown you i
cry
when i watch good cheerleading because
the stunts they throw
are insane and i think it has um out of
all like predominantly female sports it
has the highest rate of injury
um oh yeah that's what we want what kind
of yeah i mean that's an excuse
more concussions the merrier that's
that is not my opinion it does can cast
a [ __ ] out either it's not
great yeah for the um cheerleaders it is
very cool to watch um i think there's a
sort of gladiator spirit in me that
enjoys it oh okay that makes sense there
was a there was a netflix documentary
called cheer uh about um is it navarro
college maybe anyway it was this group
of cheerleaders and
um one of them turned out to be a
pedophile awkward
but um they yeah they have so if you
look up cheer netflix and watch some of
their
their um routines they are incredible
it's very impressive because in my head
i thought it was just gonna be yeah
wolverines but it's it's not bad it is
it is just
gymnastics on crack yeah it's people
being thrown into the air
with no regard for gravity or safety
it's shocking uh today's breaking news
is cheer related
um a and i'll have to get the the
details properly
uh a pennsylvania mother has been
allegedly creating deep fake photos that
she sent to her
daughter's cheerleading coach of her
teammates
naked drinking and smoking um and she
also i mean the sad thing is she also
sent them anonymous texts telling them
to kill themselves
wow but uh essentially she was trying to
bump people off she wanted kids off the
squad and so sent the cheerleading coach
well because this is
the thing about cheerleading that's
really weird and i want to clarify
obviously i'm not
actually pro the way that cheerleading
is set up at the moment where it's very
easy to get concussions and that's kind
of how the sport is
just designed um there's this weird like
moral element to cheer
where um cheerleaders at universities
for instance uh are not
you know they're not supposed to have
any pictures of them drinking or smoking
um
they need to have like a spotless
reputation it's like miss america you
can't
have given birth yes well you can't even
believe you can't have been pregnant yes
what uh yeah i wonder how does that make
you less miss america
um because you're less of a virgin and
that is
a criteria for being a miss america
correct yes
you mean you're acting surprised as if
virginity has not been one of the most
prized
feminine traits throughout history that
is true
that's true but yeah so i think it's
just this it
sort of makes me sad about cheerleader
cheerleading because um
they are incredible athletes and then
once you leave university there's
nothing there's nothing else
there's no level above that and so i'm
like yeah they should have some kind of
they should be in the olympics
so they have something to go beyond you
know well i agree with you the japanese
wouldn't i don't know i think they'd get
into it i'd say no olympics we don't
want any at all
i see yes get away get away fun thing
that came out the other day you know who
yo-yo mar is
cellist yes he is yeah my friend um
dougie very funny comedian has a joke
structure where he does yo mama jokes
but as yo-yo major
so yo-yo ma is so fat when he bows the
cello he really
bows the cello yeah you get it because
he blows it
he has much better ones than that but
that's the one i can remember
that's it yo yama is so fat that he
needs
the first chair and the second chair and
the third chair that one's better
um yo-yo ma got his covered vaccine and
uh you know what he did what he brought
his cello along with him and during the
15 minute observation period we had to
sit down he gave an impromptu
cello concert that's very nice isn't
that sweet
i can definitely imagine someone like
with her headphones in being like
i was actually trying to listen to
modest mouse yeah
yeah i mean the thing is i don't think
if if someone started playing the cello
and i looked over and i saw him i'd
probably go who's this guy think he is
yo yo ma
like that's definitely what my reaction
would be right you wouldn't think it was
actually yoyo
no and i also couldn't help but think
um when i get my vaccine
can i do a 15 minute set in the
observation area
hello can i get a suggestion for
something you've recently had put in
your arm i heard
microchip microchip here's the
suggestion so yeah good on good on yo yo
for doing that i like that um now news
story from
across the pond and it's not uh
it's not a funny story and it's not a
pleasant story but i think it's one we
should
um bring up because i don't know if
there's been much coverage in america
so in the uk a couple of weeks ago a
woman called sarah everard went missing
on her way home from a friend's house in
london
in a you know just a residential part of
london
and uh her remains were found a few days
ago
and the the alleged kidnapper and
murderer
is a metropolitan police officer and
there's there's stuff in there with the
fact that this police officer had a
complaint against them for indecent
exposure prior to this and then hadn't
been
checked this police officer also their
role
was ministerial duty so they had access
to number 10 downing street and they
were like working with politicians
um and it's it's been all over the news
in in the uk in the last week and i just
kind of wanted to
make space here for for you to kind of
talk about it because uh although i
don't
think you followed the story that much
what it prompted in the uk was a lot of
women giving their experiences with
street harassment which was kind of like
a second wind me too movement yes yeah
but much more to do with not not i've
been harassed with although obviously
there were many stories that but
here were the times i felt unsafe
because of the actions of men and
raising that issue um and men going
what what are you all about why were you
scared i was just walking closely behind
you breathing onto your neck yeah
while saying such a sweet neck
i said this is a somber section now okay
so the problem is chris
told me this the other day he was like
he comes to me very seriously
like such a feminist ella he was like
look i just want you to make space for
you to like be able to share your
experiences
of street harassment and i was like
thank you so much chris
but the problem is unfortunately i have
only had quite lull's street harassment
stories
um i don't know what it is about me
and we always talk about ashley cole
especially oh my god
okay we have to tell the story so cheryl
cole is one of the hottest people ever
to have
walked the earth uh and she's beautiful
she's only famous in britain
but anyway uh sh so she got married to
her husband
apparently because he was in a car
and he stuck his head out the window and
went like i had a nice ass and she was
like yeah
go on and then they got married it also
may have had to do with the fact that he
was
very famous england footballer ashley
cole probably in a very nice car
but it's just like as long as you can
get cheryl cole to marry you
if you shout out out at her from your
car like why would you not just
give it a go and also cheryl cole then
later divorced him and married someone
else but his surname is really difficult
to say so i think everyone just calls
her sheryl cole and even she has
acknowledged this because she just said
oh i'm cheryl now
so she's still got the surname of her
husband she's so beautiful
um okay so let me clarify a little bit
on what i said about having mainly lulls
street harassment i think i code madonna
on the madonna hall
spectrum you know what i'm talking about
uh i i do but people might not so the
madonna whole spectrum is this kind of
um
scale spectrum i don't think spectrum's
the right word anyway um
sometimes some guys will um kind of
classify
women into either madonna's aka you know
virgin virgin mary
not madonna the singer who is much more
at the [ __ ] end of the mcdonald horse
yes uh so either they're like virginal
virgin mary types
or they are horse right that's how um
these women
women get classified often and i don't
think people talk about this a lot but i
think that it's a form of privilege
to code as madonna right the way i do uh
basically
uh we live in a permissive society that
says you know
one of the freedoms that women have
gained is the freedom to make sexual
choices
uh but if you take those sexual freedoms
there is a cost
and the cost is that um there are large
groups of men who will now code you as
[ __ ]
and uh treat you worse and as someone
who doesn't code promiscuous i
um actually end up benefiting from the
madonna hall scale uh because
the same men who treat women they code
as [ __ ] badly
treat women they code madonna extra well
um
so like i've had this experience before
where there'll be a man
i know who is only ever just
incredibly like chivalrically nice to me
like lots of being like oh let me buy
this for you
can i carry your suitcase and then i'm
never surprised
when um i'll find some friends of mine
who
uh code [ __ ] on the um spectrum and
they'll be like oh yeah he
like um you know he tried to have sex
with me and i said no and he wouldn't
stop and he like followed me to my room
and i'm like yeah he would never do that
to me because of the way he has coded
us and i think that that code uh
stretches to why the street harassment i
have faced on the whole has not been as
pernicious
and as nasty um and
so you know i feel very lucky for that
and i think that that's i don't know it
isn't something i feel like people talk
about
a lot i mean obviously there's there's
street harassment which i don't think
takes any of that into account of course
you know there are
people sharing stories of their 11 year
old sister being like oh this guy pulled
up to me
she's probably just whoring it up there
wasn't she yeah well she was wearing a
schoolgirl uniform
so no i mean like obviously yes what i'm
saying is is just
one uh aspect of the whole picture i'm
not saying it's the only thing
um i have had some gross things said to
me especially if you're ever in any
situation where a man is drunk
then yes yes all sorts of gross stuff uh
but the main story that jumped to mind
when you told me this was um
once i was in london i was like 18 or 19
and
i was at a crossing where there wasn't
um
there wasn't like it was a stop sign
kind of crossing yeah
and um a white van arrived at the same
time as i did and
i made eye contact with the man in the
van and then started to cross the street
and he still making eye contact with me
just drove his car into me
um so he hit me not hard like he kind of
knocked me off my feet
and i being you know young was like
oh god i sorry i shouldn't have sorry
for crossing the street
i was just like yes i suppose i
shouldn't have crossed the street i was
so convinced that i'd done something
wrong until about half an hour later and
i was like
actually though even if i wasn't
supposed to cross the street probably
the solution was not to
hit me with your car on purpose um
so yeah that was the main one i thought
of i got hit by a car in l.a
all right chris it's actually not your
time to speak
no that was outrageous though i was just
crossing the street and this guy was had
stopped and i made eye contact with him
and i walked in front of the car
and he then accelerated and bumped into
my
the side of my knee like right where the
knee joint is so it hurt
um didn't knock me over he wasn't even
going fast and i just
looked at him just like i'm sorry and he
just put his head in his hands just like
oh not again
the fact is yes uh women face lots of
random street harassment and violence
um and i i think the point that
the any anyone who argues that it's
anything to do with what you're wearing
like that that has
an impact on that that is the reason
that these women are getting harassed
it just doesn't hold up because in santa
monica
you almost never get harassed ever in
santa monica
girls are wearing like bikini tops and
short shorts
and no one harasses them and then you go
to new york in the winter
and you're wearing like a [ __ ]
massive coat and some guy will be like
yeah
good tits and it's like what is this has
nothing to do with me this is on you
yeah do you remember we were in an uber
in santa monica and our uber driver
wound his window down and shouted at the
car next to us because he thought it was
paris hilton
oh yeah he was like paris i love your
work
and then and it was just so it was the
the second day he also did it with
another guy
who was in a really nice car it was like
a ford mustang and he he won the when he
goes
hey buddy can my friend have a go in
your car
and he points at me i'm on the back of
the uber and the
guy the guy was the guy's like huh no
and then he also started
asking the guy about his kids he told us
that he was a child actor but he didn't
want to tell us his name
because he was too famous do you
remember this
i was a very famous child actor but i
have i've actually since
tried to become uh incognito l.a
uber drivers are not like normal taxi
drivers they are their own breed wait i
have another story i have another story
of um this is not really street
harassment but it's
similar and it's an la based one um i've
told you this one before
i was in starbucks and humiliatingly i
was working on a screenplay
which was not for me okay my boss is a
screenwriter
i was helping my boss so that was you
know it was fine anyway i'm writing this
screenplay
and i have specifically sat in a chair
where no one can see what my um
screen is doing because there's really
something there's a stigma
there's a stigma about being a person in
la who sits in a starbucks and writes a
screenplay
and i've sat in a chair where only one
person can see
my laptop screen purposefully for this
reason and that person is steven
spielberg
and he says i'm gonna make you a star
kid no um so this guy sits down next to
me
and starts looking over my shoulder on
my screen and i'm like trying to like
move my laptop so he can't and then he
kind of goes
you uh you're a writer i was like no
no he was like well but you're writing a
screenplay and i was like
i just yeah but yeah
and he kind of pauses and then he goes
i uh i've written a lot of screenplays
and i was like okay i have my headphones
in right that is the universal code
for leave me the [ __ ] alone unless it's
a swarm of bees
straight ahead that was a reference to
the only man who's ever street harassed
me in a positive way to warn me about
a swarm of bees anyway it's not really
street harassment it's just
it's actually knight in shining armor
isn't it
it's a civic jupiter it's a civic duty
so can you imagine how
awful it would have been to walk into a
swarm of bees my god okay
so this guy sorry first he says i've
never
i've never seen the screenplay before
that's why i'm interested and i'm like
okay i am still trying to not talk to
you
um i'm trying i'm being i'm doing my
like extremely polite
extremely standoffish um sort of vibe
and he then says i've actually written a
lot of screenplays
and uh says you ever heard of the fresh
prince of bel-air
and i was like yeah he was like
i wrote that and i was like that's cool
and then he stands up and he looks at me
in this like
mic droppy way and he says
just thought i would tell you that
because you seem pretty stuck up and
walks out
like you know wings on his ankles
delighted with this just like harrowing
experience he's given me like i have had
my [ __ ] comeuppance because he could
have made my career
but i was a stuck-up [ __ ] and he's like
the you know fairy in the
fairy tale who punishes the the smug
girl
and uh i remember you showed me a
picture afterwards and i was like alice
that's
will smith so yeah i googled afterwards
the guy who wrote the fresh prince of
bel-air like
the writers and it was in fact not the
man who spoke to me at starbucks
big surprise there everybody i mean a
couple of weeks later i did a show
at my favorite comedy club where a
comedian who i'd never seen there before
got up and did a try
a trial set they were doing six minutes
and
they were introduced as one of the
writers for the fresh prince of bel-air
which the thing is that show around for
quite a while it's quite popular i can
imagine they had many writers on it
and in the same way you know people come
on for a season or an episode
and then don't do it um and he all he
did was just tell a six minute story
about how nice will smith was about how
fun it was working on the show about how
it gave him his big break and he was so
grateful to will smith
and the set ended without a joke
and i'm just there watching going i
really want to help this guy i want to
give him some jokes but
someone who's set is that empty of jokes
if you go up and offer them a joke
they're likely to go
no thanks i'm i'm good right because the
obvious punchline should have been
and that's the story of how became a
writer on the fresh prince of bel-air
right that would be good
um so yeah i wonder if it was the same
person just lying about everything
because that guy was tediously well i
when i sort of find amusing about this
story
my story is just this idea that he's
gone away and just been like
she'll think twice about being a
stuck-up stuck-up
so-and-so next time every story has two
sides what was the story you're thinking
of the douglas adams story
okay so this is a great story douglas
adams wrote the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy which for some reason is
every
uh british man's favorite funny book uh
i've never read it and i have had things
from it suggested
and whenever i say what does that the
person goes
that's from hitchhiker's guide as if i'm
like oh i'm sorry that i'm not king nerd
who should know this no you probably
should read it
good i i don't love it um sometimes i
feel that this reveals my secret lack of
englishness
um you know i'm not actually a citizen
and that is how
you can tell so shibboleth anyway um
what the shibboleth isn't a shibboleth a
word originally that i've never
understood what the word means oh yes
i'm pretty sure that shibboleth comes
from a word
it was a word that one group of people
could pronounce and the other group
couldn't and so therefore when you were
they were they would ask you to say that
word because it's like biblical yeah i
think so
is this like can i just recommending and
recommending
it's in the bible it's in the book of
judges
uh the ephraimites have no
sound in their language uh and so
when they were asked to pronounce
shibboleth and they couldn't they would
then be
slaughtered ah so that's the way that's
the way to deal with it correct
okay so um douglas adams was at a train
station
he bought a newspaper and a packet of
biscuits for our american listeners
cookies biscuits are cookies not
the things that people in the south are
you with gravy you okay darling yeah i
just
um
okay so he he puts his biscuits on the
table um
and then after he's reading his
newspaper for a while this other guy
comes and sits next to him at the table
it's like a you know it's a
train station waiting place right so
douglas adams opens his pack of biscuits
eats one and puts the biscuit pack down
on the table
and the guy at the table with him picks
up the biscuit
packet and just takes one of the
biscuits and eats it and
douglas adams is like how do i even
respond to this sort of like silent
you know because there are ways to make
it clear like when you're at a pub
there's
ways of opening a packet of crisps yes
there's a if you open the crisp at the
top and then down the side
so it opens out that's everyone's crisps
if you just haven't at the top well one
you've been a bit of a dick
but two that's just your christmas
exactly this is you know a biscuit
package
i'm pretty sure he's opening just the
top so it doesn't even matter you don't
share it with random people at the train
store actually not now on the edge of
covered man exactly anyway
so um david adams is dead i think yeah
so
from covered so so um this guy
eats this biscuit and dr adam's like
don't know what to say and he's too
english to say anything so he just um
eats
another biscuit and they go through the
packet like this douglas adams eats a
biscuit
the other guy eats a biscuit douglas
adams eats a biscuit the other guy eats
a biscuit
and neither of them say anything neither
of them look at each other it's very
weird they are breaking all the rules of
the social contract
and then the other guy um
like picks up his briefcase and throws
away the biscuit packet and leaves
douglas adams is really thrown by this
whole incident and then when he
gets onto the train he opens his bag
and finds his packet of biscuits
and he realizes that in fact the true
monster of the story
was him and he was like i have
i have this story and the other guy
doesn't have the punchline like he's
going around telling that story and he
doesn't know the punch line
just kind of put a bow on the the
section
um the the latest kind of happening in
the
the street harassment story is that a
vigil was held
um planned and then cancelled because
the met police said hey we're not gonna
provide any support for this
uh because it's illegal to have this
gathering uh
vigils happened anyway people met to put
flowers down
and hold candles and the police
just stormed in and broke it up like
grabbed people through arrested them and
full-on reacted
massively and so people probably felt
like this was
connected to the fact that the murderer
is probably a policeman yeah well
potentially but also i mean
you know the police and the police
commissioner cressida dick
said look crested a dick
the police commissioner said look this
wasn't lawful if it was lawful i would
have been there
but everyone pointed out well you know
last year blatant matter of protests you
let those happen because you realized
that was important
and the anti-lockdown protests happened
and the police didn't do anything they
didn't arrest anyone they let people
gather for that being like yeah these
people want to express their feelings
so i think it was this feeling that oh
because he's one of your own
which yeah it's kind of weird though
definitely sinister yeah it's it's
it's very sad as well because it was a
protest no
no it wasn't a president it was a vigil
saying hey
we have we exist in space and these are
our bodies and then
male police officers being like get on
the [ __ ] floor so
yeah um horrible horrible stuff but um
i think important to to raise
that that is going on um
that's the end of the news i have
decided
to no longer accept that you are the
main authority on the news
how dare you how dare you are my wife
uh jlo broke up with her husband oh she
did yeah but no
no they broke off their engagement and
also when you look at a picture of them
you're like
well yeah of course that's not going to
last why he's just some
guy so he's she's jennifer lopez
yeah but she's jenny from the block jeff
jeff bezos ex-wife yeah but she's not
jennifer lopez
she is a billionaire have you seen
jennifer lopez
do you like that i said billionaires oh
i do but that makes it sound like she's
the heiress to a billionaire
no i like to um i like to put feminine
i i know it's not fashionable but for
instance nothing makes me
laugh more than the idea if if i were a
doctor calling myself a doctor rhett
it's puzzling as well because um a
majorette is very different to a major
very different yes very different no
twiddling sticks
on the battlefield that is the end of
the news i did forget about um
alex rodriguez i believe his name is oh
no i was only bringing that up because
i've now taken to asking a couple other
people in my life the news and i'm
realizing it's quite a good way to
figure out like
what kind of a person you are if you
just like ask all your friends tell me
what happened in the news today
or like this week everyone has a
different perspective
i was there when you were on the phone
to your friend the other day and you
guys were talking about
the banjo player from mumford and sons
who left the band because
he posted some right wing stuff and
everyone went whoa calm down buddy
and and then we were both like mumford
and sons are still
yeah that's a relevant thing oh okay i
thought they were just sort of frozen in
2011 forever
yeah but i know i think that makes sense
the news that you
well it shows it shows you to a sort of
alarming degree
the way in which you choose the news
right i do choose the news what i'm
allowed to do no
sorry i don't mean you i mean like one
no one chooses the news
there's not you know it isn't like
in the middle ages when there's just
like one dude with a bell who comes in
and tells you the town crier
which is how i opened up the episode so
look at that little circular bow you put
on that that was very thank you
thank you tell you what yeah you're
allowed to tell me about some stuff now
uh so chris has said that i'm allowed to
tell the story of gawain in the green
knight even though
he's already had it so the most famous
version of gawain and the green knight
is written by an anonymous poet who we
tend to call the pearl poet or the
gawain poet i'm going to call him the
pearl poet
um because they wrote um the pearl which
is a very famous poem and gwen the green
knight and a couple of other ones as
well that aren't
as popular gawain is a character he's
one of the knights of the round table um
he's king arthur's nephew
so the pearl poet writes um
gwen in the green knight are i think
around the same time as chaucer is
writing
um but the language is much much weirder
because he was um he was not writing in
quarterly english like in the english of
the court
and the english we speak now evolved out
of the english of the court
so even though they write from the same
time period like it's it's much more um
the choice is so much more approachable
whereas uh going in the green light is a
little tricky to read in the original
but luckily a bunch of people have
written cool translations for instance i
think tolkien did one and so did sheamus
heaney
so there's a bunch of i would not read
the talking one
but he wanked in a bunch of orcs just
all the time
um son of bowen son of dwayne
the pearl poet opens going in the green
night
on i think christmas day or maybe new
year's day it's around that time it's
the you know
festival season and um they're at
camelot
and everyone is really young and this is
really really emphasized um like arthur
is described as as being like childish
and bright and um
everyone just it's like camelot has
just come into bloom uh and there's
always something kind of
uh depressing and sinister about camelot
because you know it will fall it's
inevitable right so even when you're
reading about uh knighthood in its
full glory it's uh a glory that's
overshadowed by the coming
doom and gawain is uh
at the table and um arthur has this
tradition
where he only um he only likes to start
eating
at feasts after something extraordinary
has happened um so and this is a thing
throughout a lot of arthurian legends
like in
in thomas mallory uh who writes the main
king arthur
stories uh that we'll kind of think of
um
in english at least in thomas mallory
what often happens is
king arthur is like no eating on
pentecost until something extraordinary
has happened and there's always a you
know like a
you know a maiden who comes in and is
like please please i'm being chased
after by an
evil goblin and then they go we'll deal
with that later but now we can eat
right but she often gets her head cut
off in strange ways anyway
so um it always works out something
extraordinary
always does happen and so they're
waiting around and suddenly
um this massive green knight rides in on
a green horse and like everything about
him is green
his armor is green his skin is green his
hair is green his eyes are green
everything he says would you like to try
this sweet corn
jolly green giant reference i don't know
if that exists in countries outside of
the uk in the u.s
yeah it is good though um so
he comes in and um he's riding his horse
in to the hall that's not a like super
normal thing to do
he has a massive axe and he says i want
to play a game
will one of you play a game with me and
all the knights are kind of like
uh no one wants to play a game
and so king arthur stands up and is like
i'll play and king arthur is like young
and impetuous and recently married to
guanova and
he can't play the game right this is one
of the fundamental problems with
chivalry
is that um the best knight gets the best
lady that's the rule
but the king cannot be the best knight
because
to be a good king and to be a good
knight are different things this is why
arthur
lancelot and gwenevere like that has to
happen just it's like formulaically
structured that way that's a love
triangle right
yes um wait no they both love gwynevere
they both love it they don't love each
other you can't really have
a love triangle unless it's bisexual
yeah so it's a it's a
love greater than symbol um so
so some people say that they were in
love otherwise
a lot i think there's an argument for it
anyway um
so to save king arthur right because
king arthur is not the best knight if he
fights the green knight he will get
defeated and then camelot will collapse
so to save arthur gawain stands up and
goes please please let me
do this instead and so he goes to uh
the green knight and um the green knight
says this is the game
you can strike a blow on my body
anywhere you like
with my axe and in a year i will return
the blow
and um if you withstand it then you can
have the axe
um as a reward and this seems like a
sneaky trick right because it's like
well okay if i kill you you can't kill
me back right so
okay so um gawain raises the axe
and strikes off the giant's head
and it rolls to the ground and the giant
doesn't fall
instead he walks neatly over to his head
picks it up holds it under his arm and
the head says
see you in a year at white chapel uh
sorry a green chapel
and uh and then leaves and
poor gawain is just left
so appalled that he has entered into
this unwinnable fight right because now
the green knight is gonna hit him with
an axe what's he supposed to do he
spends the year
kind of dreading this end point right
and um there's some really beautiful
language about how the year is wearing
on but uh
in the year is cyclical right there will
come more winters but for gawain it's
like he's rapidly rushing on to the end
of his life a human life is linear
whereas nature is cyclical
um and finally he realizes he has to
start
walking to try and find this place green
chapel so i think around october he
leaves
and uh it kind of skims over this bit
it's like he fights some dragons he
meets some monsters he has advocates
tolkien goes off on a long quest with a
ring
anyway so um we get to winter he still
hasn't found green chapel he's
really hungry he's tired he just wants
to go to church on christmas eve so that
he can think about god
um it's so cold that his armor is like
freezing all around him
and then he sees this castle in the
distance a beautiful castle it's it's so
white and pure it looks as if it was
paired out of paper against the horizon
and when he gets to the castle everyone
treats him so well
and the lord of the castle is a guy
called bertilak and bertilak um
leads him leads him to you know
beautiful bedchamber and is like you can
rest here as long as you like um
green chapel is really nearby i can just
show it to you on the day
um and sir gawain is relieved
and the next morning
bertilak offers a new game bertilak is
like all right
this is the game i suggest um you stay
in
while i go hunting and then at the end
of the day i'll give you everything i
won while i was hunting and you give me
everything you want while you're at the
castle
and gawain's like sure and
uh he's lying in bed when bertilak's
wife comes in
and this bit is quite funny because but
gawain tries to pretend he's asleep
so because he's like oh god i don't want
to deal with this and this like
very hot woman is like climbing into his
bed and kissing him and he's being like
oh sorry i just woke up um because he
really does not want to deal with it
because
uh it's really hard to deal with to like
know what rule to follow because
uh as a courtly knight he should be you
know kind of a womanizer but also
he's staying at bertalex castle he can't
[ __ ] his wife so
um he they had this argument back and
forth and finally he agrees to kiss her
so they kiss
in bed for a while and then she leaves
and then at the end of the day bertilat
comes back
and gives um gawain like a massive
boar or something a stag or something
gross and um
gawain meanwhile goes up to bertilak and
kisses him and he's like there you go
that's what i got
and vertilax like who kissed you and go
away it's like not telling
and then they do this game a couple more
times but on the third
day um each time going kisses but like
in the evening right
on the third day um the wife is like
i want to give you a gift and gwen's
like i don't want to accept your gift
and she's like oh what because you think
i'm not good enough for you and gawain's
like no no you are
and she goes okay come on let me just
give you something i have a
magic girdle that prevents anyone who
wears it from being
killed or hurt and he's like that
actually would be very convenient at
this juncture
so she gives him the green girdle um and
he ties around his waist
and at the end of the day when bertilak
comes back gawain kisses him on the
mouth
but does not give him the girdle and
then he goes to green chapel
um he's guided there by a servant who um
suddenly freaks out and it's like i
can't go anywhere any nearer this place
gives me the heebie-jeebies and leaves
and as gawain gets closer the only sound
you can hear is the sound of someone
sharpening an axe on a grindstone which
is pretty
uh horrible and then when he gets there
he sees the green knight
and um the green knight's like all right
come on get down your knees and so
gawain very sadly gets down on his knees
and
uh the green knight lifts up the axe and
brings it down
to gawain's neck and then pauses right
when he's about to hit going in the neck
and gawain flinches and the green knight
says hey don't flinch and go wayne says
okay i won't but i want to point out
that my head won't grow back
if you cut it off so i am more scared
than you were obviously
and then uh the green knight does the
same thing again he does a faint he like
brings down the axe and stops
and then the last time the green knight
actually nicks his neck
right so it's neck is bleeding but only
a nick like it's not dangerous
and gawain is like so relieved and it's
like what is going on and the green
knight is like i'm bertalak
in disguise oh my god it's all to do
with morgan lafaye who's always a
troublemaker
um anyway point is the green knight is
like the first
faint of the axe was because you played
the game on the first night the second
faint of the axe was because you played
the game on the second night you gave me
the kisses that my wife gave you
but on the third day you did not give me
the magic girdle and so you broke the
rules of the game and so therefore i
hurt you
but only a little because it was for a
reasonable reason
the wanting to save your life and
bertilak thinks this is all quite good
fun
and is like you can keep the girdle like
that's you know this is lols do you want
to come back and have some drinks uh my
castle ut desert
but um gawain has had his entire
identity shattered he's like oh my god
i'm a coward i broke the rules i'm not a
good knight i should be ashamed of
myself forever
this is it i can never love myself ever
again or have any respect for myself as
a knight
and he goes back to camelot and no one
understands how he feels
and everyone's like oh what a great
story gawain we're all gonna start
wearing
green girdles two to show like how funny
we think that story is
and gawain's like every time i look at
that green girdle i remember all the
worst parts of my personality that i
hate about myself the most
and everyone at camelot is just like ha
ha and the story ends with gawain just
feeling terrible forever and camelot
embracing uh a doomed form of morality
poor gawain very sad there's a dove
patel
film coming out about green the green
light well i hope he doesn't make the
same mistakes that gawain did
thank you very much oh sorry was that
very long and very boring no no
it was very interesting it was very long
how long was it it wasn't as long as it
would have been if it was the tolkien
version
that's the end of the news which means
it's now time for a freestyle app based
on
what happened alice has the suggestions
we have a beat it's about to drop
what's the first suggestion gonna be uh
it's gonna be it's gonna be the um
meghan markle oprah interview
sitting down looking into you eyes
meeting across it that's the interview
oprah on the sofa or maybe an armed
chair and harry and megan are there with
the ginger hair
no baby just a lot of chickens hoping
it'll make the rounds get the people
clicking that's what piers morgan's
opinion was he thought she was aiming
slightly above the japanese don't want
yo there'd be plenty people don't want
olympics 2021 because they had to
postpone it
they say tokyo will not home it 91
of them say no spectators no tourists
coming round
save it for later cancel it wait another
four years but i love the olympics
imagine my fears i don't deep fake
photos of chelsea
if you're a 50 year old mother in your
middle with your cheerleader
team or your daughter get ready cause
police report you
for creating deep fake send it by the
text say it check out this hussy she be
giving neck to a
random guy while drinking and smoking
but the photoshop was not bad so
revoking wait i said not bad i mean
it was shabby alice is talking yeah
she's pronouncing badly
i wrote on the fresh prince oh in a
coffee shop taking that time
looking at the screenplay guide to your
right saying oh
god's a little screenplay you're right
ting and alice says
please ignore me he's like let me tell
you a long boring story
i wrote on the fresh prince of bel-air
alice is there like
blonde hair in the chair in the
starbucks the guy says wow
you're a real [ __ ] you're a real
massive cat i didn't i was gonna help
you
i'm gonna aid oh at the white house they
can't stay
why because they're jumping up and
getting kind of scratchy secret service
guys like yo
major catch me and run away in the
presidential home
major hunt him down and start chewing on
a bone but the bone inside his shin or
his thigh
he's like put these down
making out every single night because he
did it dirty with his wife and so he
comes home
says i caught balls twice and then
gawain says oh let me give you a smooch
on the third night gawain did not tell
the truth so
burlap was upset he really cried in
saying ah i'll reveal myself the green
giant the green knight looking at my
girdle
going went back to camelot and heard all
the little cheers through his tears
let me say what i seen some old guy over
there with a vaccine whipping out a
cello this elderly fellow
i said oh why is he trying to make it
more mellow the environment was really
nice we had the little elevator music
and now this guy is family's gonna abuse
it but then i realized he's really good
playing there with the strings on pieces
of wood going side to side what a nice
thing he gives
the rest everybody get the arm and a
hole like a cigarette when they're
pumping it man
you get a lot of cash billions going
mackenzie scott
divorcing jeff bezos he could not reach
her on the phone afterwards she'd be
[ __ ] that teacher and then they got
married
yeah that's what's up i'm assuming
mckenzie got the mad prenup
otherwise well he's gonna break up and
leave you and take a lot of
money i prefer wikipedia to amazon
in terms of websites that are not bad um
we watch no mad land that's what we did
this week yeah it was sad wasn't it that
was sad but it's the end of the show so
you can't tell you about that
well that was a very good rap chris
thank you very much alice wynn you're
you're very nice
thank you you madonna madonna
um thank you very much for providing me
with suggestions why don't you provide
our lovely listeners slash viewers with
where they can find you on instagram
chris at let them eat books with
underscores instead of spaces
i also do reviews of films that we watch
sometimes yeah yeah
the little stories they're always very
entertaining i like them a lot um
and don't forget you can find out about
my private zoom shows by going to
the link which in the description of
either of these formats
um and sign up my mailing list through
that description as
well and find me on instagram chris
turner comedy it's been a pleasure
chatting to you alice wynn
and to you not alice wins um unless you
share the name in which case oh my god
we're totally married
um goodbye from me
and me goodbye from
goodbye goodbye from both of us